you should never feel comfortable you
should be happy and dissatisfied
if I heard a great quote the other day
like follow your heart and your body
will catch up and I think that that's
the way it is with everything at the
table
it's always full of excuses because
they're valid there's a lot of people
against you you are a warrior don't ever
let anybody take what you're supposed to
get the motivation whattcha top ten with
believe nation
he's Terry Crews and here is my take on
his top ten rose to success vol 3
enjoy the comfort zone is dangerous when
you're comfortable you are at most
danger you're the comfort zone is
somewhere you need to you should never
feel comfortable you should be happy and
to satisfy you ever anybody ever tell
you beat hey look you know what just be
satisfied with what you got
don't believe or get him away from you
you should never be satisfied with what
you got because the tips to get more
makes you into something better all the
time
don't let anybody tell you a man you
know you should just be happy with no
you should double your business triple
it truly what you just be when I got
this book called the master key system
and what was wild to me it broke down
some things in ways that I can
understand because you hear certain
things but you have to hear things in a
different way so that you can grasp it
and one of the the concepts in the book
is that in order to have you have to do
and in order to do you have to be and I
sat and I you know I would contemplate
this thing like a lot and I was like
what does this mean like what is this me
in it you know it sounded like gibberish
started a little bit like what is is
what was will be you know that kind of
what will be words it will be again you
know okay but but once you really
examined it is that and I'll bring
Fitness into this yes please with
Fitness you know you are fit before your
body ever gets in shape you have to be
Fitness like you know every person who
lost 200 pounds can tell you the moment
way back then when they knew they were
going to be their ideal weight
that's the moma
they it was B it was my ideal way I I'm
going to be that and and then your body
just goes right into it I heard a great
quote the other day like follow your
heart and your body will catch up and I
think that that's the way it is with
everything is it not master key system
book broke it down where you I had to
say like I always had dreamed of like
man one day I'm gonna have money one day
and I said wait a minute
I'm rich I'm rich now and this is they
didn't have a pity but when you do
things and you say okay now that I'm
rich what would a rich man do that's
this is really important do you see what
would a rich man do and I started doing
things that rich people did and once I
did it I had but that's the kind of the
way fitness success any goal any
aspiration you must be it now that book
do you think you want to write you know
that thing you want to accomplish you
have to be it now you are an author so
now what do authors do authors write and
when Arthur's right they have a book and
I'm telling you it sounds really really
really simple but once you get it
forever you will you'll never think of
anything the same way again rule number
three take accountability one thing I
realize is that at certain times in a
man's life he's all either a fool he's a
victim or he's a king mm-hm and when
you're a fool you're like you goof it
all up you know well you know it but you
think there are no consequences for your
actions but there are always
consequences for every act you do
everything good or bad but then when you
mess your whole life up being a fool you
become a victim now oh my God look you
know what you know why you know why I
did that cuz I was black you know what
because I grew up at all that religion
and I'm my father
like you don't he beat my mom you know
that right or look at this look at the
situation I'm from Flint Michigan man
it's hard it's hard for a black man in
this suit in this society and this way
we did it I had and let me tell you the
table is always full of excuses because
they're valid yeah a lot of people
against you and you can say oh my god
this table this pull it's like man you
know this is the reason why I'm like
this and this is this is a man you never
run out and you always stay down always
you always end but the King stage but
when you realize wait a minute this is
your table mm-hmm wait a minute this is
your room you have to accept whatever
you are letting into your life good or
bad as a king you can tell people get
out of your Court as a king you don't
have to accept any of those excuses yeah
as a king you have to know that you are
responsible for your life good and that
you did that
so as a king if something's not right
it's your responsibility to change it
rule number four be a warrior when I'm
at the gym man and I don't play when I'm
in the gym I do not play I make knowing
I live I throw I have power clean and I
was like okay and the weights were
flying up and this guy comes by hey he's
yelling this is I'll pay jumps be just
like everybody else right he's like man
yo you calm that down you're making us
look bad
[Laughter]
let me tell you something man I said hey
hey hey listen
I say you and sir don't talk to me so
don't ever talk to me
I said you mind your business you hear
me let me tell you something oh this is
you are a warrior don't ever let anybody
take what you're supposed to get and I
knew what I was supposed to get I was
there in that gym to get what I was
there to get and I don't care what you
say I don't care what you look like I
don't care how I look
it takes courage to look like a fool it
does let me tell you when you're in a
gym and you're out of shape you don't
look good you don't look good when
you're learning something when you go to
school and you they give you the grade
and everybody thought he didn't do it
didn't do good you got a D you feel that
hurt you gonna what you gonna do never
take a test no you get back up and you
get what you are supposed to get and I
wasn't letting it happen and what I bet
people have always said well you know be
the humble Jerry be humble but you know
what humble is humble is the fact that I
could I could lift all I can lift the
whole gym but I use it to lift groceries
with a little old lady
that's humility that's humility that you
use the thing that you're strongest at
to help others that's the essence of
humility I walk in my quiet I run this
I'm trying to tell you I walk on these
TVs I walk on these sets and I listen
you can't walk in their night whatever
whatever you walk it up and slide comes
there anyone you were seeing with you
and you like well I'm just good enough
to come on slide like what what here's
the thing and they go ahead that's
pretty good I like that
you know I mean I had to face up Arnel
and do my thing but you gotta know you
can do it it was no humidity that
doesn't work you should go in your job
like that not rude never rude it's not
rude but let me tell you they're gonna
take notice they're gonna take notice
and they're gonna go man this dude is
please he's above his place he's working
he's out working everybody in fact he's
too big for where we got it all so if
you want to learn how to have confidence
like Terry Crews and others check my 254
series its inscriptions and it's free
and you love whatever you're thinking
about it you will not get it until you
take action you gotta get rid of those
haters in your mind rule number five and
get rid of self-sabotage there have been
times when you can be self-destructive
and you think it's something else or you
think like I discovered for a long time
like if I show up late or something
twice I don't want it hmm and you get
what you desire you're everything about
you you get what you want now
the way your life is truly you want it
and that's now that's hard that's hard
to say because I feel like don't wait
there's so many other options is this
and this and this and this but the truth
is is that if you wanted something
different you change it and that hit me
like it's scary because if I failed or
if I did me if I showed up wrong or
messed up on something I was like I
didn't really do what it took to get it
get rid of any what I call self-sabotage
and you can achieve whatever you need
well over six forgives
how do you in your own heart feel about
forgiveness where people have done
something wrong to you first of all
forgiveness is a requirement I remember
when Donald sterling did all his thing I
went on a press tour I was doing a
precedent for blended and not the whole
Donald sterling thing was going on
and I said we need to forgive Donald
sterling you can look it up on YouTube
right now
Wow and black people like hell no but I
said listen let's sing the big big thing
about forgiveness is that it's not for
him mm-hmm or them it's for you it's for
you now
forgiveness and accountability go ahead
and and see what people think is
forgiveness me now I'm free no it
doesn't you the back holding you
accountable as a part of forgiveness I
forgive you I let you go I'm balling
this lawsuit like that's as far as
forgiveness goes I forgive you me
meaning meaning hey man you know what
I'm not gonna let anything you do affect
me in a negative way mm-hmm your son I
mean in fact I'm gonna let it propel me
to do more courageous acts to help other
people and I had to forgive my father
man mmm not the hard liver my youngest
memory is my father hitting my mother in
the face and knocking around okay I had
to forgive him but the thing is
forgiveness is great but he expected
okay so now everything's good I think no
no you can't come in my house and ruin
my house yeah I mean there I actually
forgave him and in blocked his number
yeah you see what I'm saying see but
that's what we're we getting getting it
mixed up because what happens is with a
smooth toxic guy knows how to manipulate
that come on baby forgave me right let
me back in it's like ah you've already
crossed that line now forgiveness is
like you know what I forgive you go your
way
mmm goodbye that's the best kind of
forgiveness man rule number seven know
yourself worse well I'm here to tell
people and I'm here to tell everyone
it's good news this is good news here we
go good news is sports itself is just a
small party of life and this is what I
try to tell be but that's a I've never
been more successful than I am now
ever and I'm not the only one see a lot
of people say well you were special your
Tarique really about it ain't nothing
special about me
nothing not one thing special about me
except the fact that I had the courage
to do it the courage to just go out
there because there's so many athletes
who now when they're done they get
depressed and they're out because the
thing is NFL athletes MBA athletes what
happens is you become your wins you are
now bigger better than everybody but
when you lose and when you out now you
worse than everybody and you had a uni
side I always gotta tell these guys
don't that that has nothing to do with
your worth as a human being period and
that's my message to all these athletes
that your life starts when the game is
over y'all the thing is not one NFL
owner got there by playing football not
one you could do the same thing you know
then it's like the people who are owning
it and running it they didn't play well
and I'm trying to tell you that's not
your only way to riches through the
rainy season I once put ball ended in
the entertainment thing it kind of
happened I started I had to learn like
you can't fight your way out of things
you have to think your way out of things
and I noticed how my wife behaved and I
noticed how actually how women behave
because women have to think their way
out of all kinds of situations whereas
guys can we can muscle our way through
and do other stuff and and whatever but
I realized that that was not getting me
anywhere and my wife really taught me
that vulnerability is not weakness
that I had to be vulnerable but I had to
be authentic at the same time and she
would always always talk to me and tell
me that Terry you have to you and she
would always tell me the truth right
there's nothing more valuable than
somebody who's gonna speak the truth
into your life and she would constantly
tell me this is wrong the way you're
acting right now is awful and I'm just
like I'm like all these other guys
because that's what guys do you compare
yourself to all the other guy and you
say but compared to them I'm good right
and you know she's like I'm done
you gonna be I'll never forget the first
time I had a big job I remember I got a
big movie and whatever and I I remember
I was walking around at this party and I
had a cigar and I was walking around and
I was man I had the swag I had the whole
thing she was like okay you can stay
over there I'm gonna be over here and I
was like we're talking about I'm waiting
I'm waiting and she was like no baby
uh-uh nope nope and I was like whoa and
I realized just in those little ways I
was losing her and so I had to put the
scar down and I'll come back over there
she said not asked my degree I was like
wow
be mindful up is so mindful lately
because there are times when I'm sitting
around and I'm like why am i irritated
I'm not irritated by something there's
and then I realized it was something I
said or something that filled before I
go into any interview I have to check my
own heart there's times I may be mad at
my wife and I take it out on somebody in
the interview right you know what I mean
and you go whoa why did I say man dude
you have no idea how deep you go that's
the deal people know I don't know no
listen and this is another thing I know
the knowledge that I am capable of
unspeakable evil means I can counteract
it yeah but when you just think no man I
would never do something like that
don't ever say a thing like that I would
now could the whole country of Germany
thought we would never do that
right I mean it was a time when when I
was a kid we were riding a pack of
flatbed trucks on the freeway at 70
miles an hour and wave at the cops and
the cops way back until kids started
dying on the freeway but maybe we should
buckle up yeah and there was a time
where everybody just accept it like you
can dry the back of a flatbed truck on a
freeway right do that yeah and those
things just we think we know but I think
we're just right now on the cusp of
realizing who we are and remember 10 the
last one before a very special
cliff is keep growing you don't grow you
die in you if you do not expand your
business expanding your family expand
your life expand your mind expand if you
don't push to grow your diet and what
you have will be taken and I don't want
to see that happen to anybody
now there's such a bonus tip from Carrie
on how to be creative that I really
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
is some of the three-point landing
question it's time to move from just
watching the video and taking action in
your life for business here we go
question number one who do you need to
forgive in your life to move forward
number two what are three ways that you
will commit to keep growing this week
and number three what will you do on a
daily basis to remind yourself of your
self-worth my thing is I never saw once
I crack that egg on the inside of me
like that
that the image and who I was became one
person I could do anything
Wow there was no rules go host act you
create a furniture language paint yeah
do whatever there's no rules there's
nobody to tell you Amy that's not what a
man does no no no creativity works like
do whatever you want whatever your
vision sees and back as far as you can
take it you know what I mean Pablo
Picasso said you know whatever you can
imagine is real that kind of creativity
man
if you want Morty recruit struck at the
other top 10 video I'm with hit the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I like to call myself a
motivational do or I hate talking to my
real toughness is when you can tell
people you know I'm in pain I don't feel
good right now